what is serialization and der
serialization okay let's look at this we
have already discussed this that usually
we have a client let's say we have this
client it's a browser all right it's a
browser let's say it's Chrome and this
is called front end right in our typical
technical language and usually we
communicate with a
server that's running in your Local Host
or it's running somewhere remote in
cloud in AWS or gcp or Azure anywhere
and the client communicates with the
server through some means of network
communication it can be through HTTP
right our traditional rest API end
points or it can be through grpc or it
can be through websocket we have
different means of communications for
clients and servers to communicate with
each other for this example and
throughout the series since we are
focusing on HTTP or our traditional rest
API style communication let's assume
this client is a Javascript app can be a
react or angular or view any JavaScript
framework or Library it's a Javascript
app usually most of the client side apps
are built with JavaScript highly
interactive app in order to send a
request to the server the client has to
make an HTTP request which we have
already discussed in the previous videos
looks something like this get etc etc
the URL the
HTTP right some
domain.com
slath something like this so either a
get request or if it's a post request we
have the URL and Below we have the
headers and below that we have the
request body and this is how front end
sends the data the request with all the
information that is required or the
client wants to send to the server this
is how client sends information to the
server and the server responds with some
response which the client is able to
pass and make sense of so the thing to
notice here and the thing to focus here
in this chapter or in this session is
how clients and servers can make sense
of the data that is being received or
the data that is being sent for example
in our case the client is a Javascript
app and the server can be a rust app
right the web server is built with rust
language so in
JavaScript let's say we are sending this
object right and we have
name is some
string we are sending this and after we
send this
in the request body and it reaches the
server which is a rust
server how does the server take this
data and is able to make sense of it it
is able to make sense of it in its own
format in its own data types because
JavaScript and rust have completely
different data types JavaScript is a
completely Dynamic language it is not
compiled on the other side rust is very
strict when it comes to types and it is
a compiled language the all the data
types are completely different from
JavaScript so how does this happen how
one data type that is transmitted over a
network is able to reach another machine
that is somewhere else in the internet
and it is able to make sense of that
data and perform some business logic and
send some response
and the client is again able to make
sense of that response and able to show
some UI or perform some business logic
how does this all come together so
before we talk about data transmission
over the Internet it's very good to have
some knowledge about OSI
model if you're a CS student you might
have already come across it if you're
not then you don't have to completely
Master it or understand every aspect of
it like IP packets or data frames etc
etc but having a good high level
overview or a high level understanding
of how
these OSI layers different layers of
network communicate with each other over
the internet to transmit some kind of
data
over Hardware right we have different
types of layers called application
layers and network layers right there
are a lot of good resources in YouTube
or any other platform that you can look
up and just get a high level
understanding of OSI model and going too
deep into this is out of scope for this
video and will probably take too much
time and people who are way better than
me have explained this in a way better
format and now assuming you have a high
level understanding of OSI models or
just are aware of what this model is and
how it helps make sense of data
transmission over the internet now the
layer on top is called application
layer and after all the layers the
bottom layer is called physical layer or
you can call it top call it bottom does
not matter right these two are on the in
the opposite end of each other right and
the same thing happens on the server
side here in the server we have
application
layer and in the bottom we have physical
layer
and there are layers in between now
imagine if you were asked to solve this
problem the problem that we have two
machines that
are in different
locations and they are connected over
the internet right let's say over the
cloud and you are asked you have to come
up with some way or some technique or
some protocol to go with the tech
technical terminology you have to come
up with a way so that clients or one
machine is able to send data to another
machine and they should be able to parse
that data and make sense of it in a way
that it is language agnostic and a very
obvious and common solution that you
might come up with is figuring out a
common
standard which is just a fancy way of
saying you will come up with some set of
rules and you will ask both the clients
and the server to agree that this is the
standard or this is the format that the
client should send the data in or the
server should send the response in so
that client does what it needs to do
during the execution of the session of
the user and when sending data to the
server it transforms or converts
whatever the logic is from that language
let's say from
JavaScript to this standard this format
and sends it over the network and when
receiving the server takes that data
from that standard and converts it into
its own standard let's say it's rust so
it converts it into a struct in Rust and
it understands the data format and
whatever it needs to do and when sending
the response it converts that data let's
say from
rust
truct into this standard this common
format and sends it over the internet
and again the client reads it and parses
it into JavaScript and it's it's able to
do whatever it needs to do this part
this is a solution what is the solution
the solution is coming up with a
serialization
standard common standard that the both
client and the server agree to send and
receive data and to summarize this whole
thing realization and derealization is
basically converting to and from data to
a common format so that during
transmission or storage we'll get to the
storage part but from this example we
can say that the serialization and
deserialization is basically converting
data from and to a common format while
transmission so that it is domain agnos
tic or in this case language agnos that
machines and servers and clients from
different domains and different
languages from different environments
are able to make sense of that data and
are able to respond to that data and
before we dive deep into the
serialization standard I just want to
make a note here that which I have
already mentioned that backend is a huge
domain and there are a lot of
Technologies hundreds of technologies
that is used in the industry so it's
impossible to understand the concepts
behind all of those Technologies what we
will do in this video and in this whole
playlists we'll go with the most used
Technologies for example for the data
transmission there are a lot of
Technologies getting used for example
HTTP and websockets and you have
grpc etc etc so we'll go with HTTP since
rest apis are still the most common
means of communication over the Internet
between clients and servers and as a
backend engineer if you are aware of and
have good experience in HTTP then you're
good to go you can learn all these other
Technologies along the way you just need
something which is used all of the
industry to get started and get some
experience and you can learn
Technologies as you progress over your
career in the same way for databases we
have a lot of different types of
databases we have
relational right we have non-
relational in relational we have
postgress we have MySQL we have
sqlite
right same way in non- relational we
have
mongodb we have Dynamo DB from
AWS a lot of different options for
databases but in this playlist we'll go
with post gra right it's one of the most
popular relational databases and is used
by a lot of companies and mostly the
first choice these days for a lot of
startups and Enterprise servers in the
same way we have different types of
serialization
Standards
standards and we will go with a popular
one the one that gets used I won't give
a number but if I had to given number
I'll say 80% of the time which is
Json is one of the most popular
serialization and deserialization
standards that gets used for client and
server
communication we have other standards
for serialization der serialization that
does not necessarily gets used for HTTP
communication but definitely gets used
for serialization for example we have
yl we have XML and inside serialization
standards these three including Json and
XML yaml these things are
called
text based
serialization right we have another type
of serialization standard which is
called binary
format binary format and in binary
format we have all again different types
and the most popular one is called
protuff we have other formats also like
a etc etc for serialization standards we
have text based and binary format and
inside text base we have different types
called Json yaml XML and for now we will
only focus on Json since that's the most
popular choice for sttb based
communication between clients and
servers now that's clear let's jump into
Json and this is what a typical
Json object looks
like so to give you a little context
Json stands for JavaScript object
notation and you can read more about
Jon's history and its Evolution from
other resources but just to give an idea
of Json from the looks of it and from
the behavior looks very similar to a
JavaScript
object and
and that's why you can understand why
it's name like that JavaScript object
notation but it is not limited to
JavaScript and it is used everywhere you
will find Json in configuration files
and of course uh during HTTP rest API
transmission between clients and servers
you will find Json in log file Json is a
very popular choice for logging
application data or server data during
runtime it has a lot of use cases for
this use case we are going to focus on
transmission of course this is what a
typical Json looks like in the looks of
it you can understand it's completely
human readable and that is one of the
strong points of Json it was made to be
human readable and the data types are
also pretty fundamental if you are even
a little familiar with different
programming concepts for example things
to focus here is we have a starting CIS
and then ending one and all the keys are
inside double codes so this is one rule
you have to follow the keys will be
inside double Cotes and they will be
strings you cannot make any other data
type as a key keys will be inside double
codes and there will be strings and in
the value it can be a string or it can
be a number it can be a bullion or it
can be an array or it can be another
object right Json can be a nested object
also for example let's say you have here
an address field inside the same Json
you have a column here and you can start
another crais here you can write
country you can say it's a string it's
India and your phone number right phone
number and it can be a number something
3 4 5 6 and you have to provide an
ending
CIS right this is the typical structure
of Json that's all there is to it uh you
would find a lot of Concepts in Json
these are the things you have to
remember there has to been starting
Braes and ending craes and the keys will
have to be inside double quotes and
there will there will be strings and in
the value you can provide an string a
number a bullion or an array or a nested
object which will again have the same
characteristics of the initial object
right there'll be Keys which will be
inside double quotes and there'll be
strings and they will have values again
in the same characteristics so that's
all you need to know about
Json this is one of the most popular
serialization standard that we use
during client and server communication
so let's just see a simple demo in fact
let's just see our earlier demo that we
saw in the previous video and this time
we'll focus on the request and response
format the serialization and
deserialization format and see how it
looks like pretty much looks like the
same thing that we saw here but let's
just see in a real environment here we
have our BP Su interface and this is the
earlier demo that we saw in our previous
video but this time we'll hit an API and
focus on the data format that gets
transmitted and the data format that
gets received from the client and from
the server so let's just hit the post
API that was here post
books and let's go to http history and
open this
one and let's expand this and go to the
request and L this is a post request and
we are calling this path API SL books
this is the data that we are sending so
let's just focus on the request first
here we can see our earlier discussed
Json format we have a crais and we have
all the keys that are double CED and
those are strings and we have a number
here and two strings like ID title and
author this thing gets transmitted over
the network so now one thing that I want
to mention here is if you went deep into
the OSI model so you must have come
across that from application layer to it
gets converted into Data frames and etc
etc it gets converted into IV packets
and there is transmission layer and in
the end it gets converted into bits with
0 one 01 stuff stuff Network related
stuff right so as a backend engineer the
thing you have to focus here is the
mental model you should have is you can
assume that you have this client and you
have this server right the client has to
adhere to a particular standard let's
say this is
Json and the server has to understand
this standard called Json we transmit
this the server understands this and
returns some data again in Json format
with respect to your knowledge of OSI
model which has different different
layers which the data gets converted
into different different formats from
data frames to IP packets to physical
bits that gets transmitted D with
voltage signals over Optical F etc etc
the mental model to have is in
application layer gets converted into
Json as a backend engineer you don't
that's all your responsibility is does
not matter what format it gets converted
into after this point that is not of
your concern so it gets converted into
different different formats and then in
the end 0 1 01 and then again it reaches
the server reaches 0 1 01 that's it
reads all the bits and does all the
network related stuff then it again gets
converted into Json only in the server
side also does not matter what the
intermediary steps convert the data into
that does not matter before receiving
before in the receiving end of the
server the data again gets converted
into this Json format only and the
server only gets to read the Json so you
don't have to worry about all the
intermediary steps now that's clear this
is the request Json that the client
sends and the server understands this
and it takes this ID and all these
information and adds it here and
responds with another Json right it's
another
Json so again we have the opening calias
and ending calias we have one key which
is an array and each array has an object
again it is also in Json format you can
see all the keys are in double codes and
it has values in number and string
formats and this is an array and it's
received by the client and the client
understands it and if you see here we
are rendering it here so the client is
able to receive this data from the
server and it is able to make sense of
it it is able to pass it and it is able
to render it in its own way right in
this case it is Javascript but it can be
PHP also etc etc right this is how Json
flow looks like in client server model
in real life scenarios it does not have
a lot of Concepts realizing in dis
realization do not have a lot of
Concepts it is a phenomena in the
backend world that that exists you have
to know that it exists and Json getting
transmitted by the client to the server
the server passing it understanding it
making sense of it and responding with
appropriate data to the client and again
the client passing it understanding it
making sense of of it this whole flow is
called
serialization
and der
serialization so again to summarize
serialization and deserialization are
the techniques using which data is
converted into a common format a
standard format so that clients can send
data to the server in that format and
the servers can receive that data make
sense of pass it and perform the
business logic and send the data again
in that common format so that the client
can again do the same thing realization
and dation are basically dealing with
standard format so that data is
understandable across domains and
language that's all there is to it in
serialization and deserialization